[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
would you like to hear an amazing fact
back in 1956
Harry Delayer a horse riding instructor
from Long Island went to a horse auction
because of his late arrival he missed
all the best horses all that was left
were the rejects being sold to the
slaughterhouse that's when Harry spotted
a thin filthy plowers already loaded on
the truck pleadingly the gray horse
looked into Harry's eyes and something
clicked
Harry offered its owners $80 and then
the eight-year old horse he named snow
man he began to use as a training horse
snowman regained his help under Harry's
tender care and was eventually sold to a
neighbor for a hundred and sixty dollars
however the horse missed his redeemer so
much he could not be contained
he jumped any obstacle to get back to
Harry's farm that's when Harry finally
realized snowman had an amazing jumping
potential and he took the horse back
this began snowman's wildly successful
showjumping career the former plow horse
went on to beat all of the thoroughbreds
even winning the Triple Crown he was
beloved by riders of all ages and skill
levels once winning two major jumping
championships in the same day he became
famous for his willingness to work with
children and easily jump over the backs
of other full-size horses you can see
while he was called the Cinderella horse
after being saved from the
slaughterhouse in the nick of time
snowman became incredibly famous and
lived another twenty two years he
appeared on numerous television shows
and was featured twice in Life Magazine
in addition snowman had three books
written about him as well as a
documentary film
this Cinderella horse went from being a
doom plow horse to an international
champion because someone had mercy and
redeemed this dirty horse from death you
know the Bible says that someone has
paid a great price to redeem you from
the hopeless end and give you an endless
hope stay with his friends were going to
learn more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
and our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and it is always good to be
back on the air and live with you to
talk about the Word of God nothing is
more important than that GPS it tells us
how to get to the kingdom and receive
eternal life in the future peace in this
life you'd like to know more about that
book and you have any questions about
the Bible
we've got lines that are wide open
here's a number one more time 800 God
says that's 800 for six three seven two
nine seven 800 four six 372 97 will
bring your questions into tonight's
program and as always beginning of the
program is a great time to call and get
your question on tonight's broadcast my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross and good evening frames impassive
egg let's start the program with prayer
dear father in heaven we thank you that
we can open up your word and study
together we want to ask the Holy Spirit
as always to come and guide our hearts
our minds though we realize that the
Bible is your book we need the Spirit of
God to understand it so bless those who
are listening and be with us here in the
studio in Jesus name Amen amen
well past that I yield in the program
with one of those great comeback stories
of a horse that was really doomed for
the slaughter and then somebody had
compassion on the horse
this post turned out to be this great
champion horse the story is a great day
heartwarming and you know the several of
them more famous horses that seem to
come from nowhere and do great things
but this one in particular here was
someone who had compassion on just a
no-good horse and that horse returned
his act of compassion it seems with just
a devotion and a commitment it's kind of
a neat story yeah I'm you know when you
read up on it it looks like there was a
bond between Harry matter of fact one of
the books is called hearin snowman and
there was a bond the horse seemed to
know that he had been saved and who
knows what kind of life he had before
when he was a plow horse must not have
been very good if his owner was ready if
he was all dirty and he was ready to be
you know sold for virtually nothing and
but that person totally missed the
potential of this horse he hooked to a
plow and he was a champion mm-hmm and
but Harry spotted that and and the horse
when you read about it was willing to do
anything that Harry he would jump as
high as Harry tried to get him to jump
because he always wanted to please him
and also very gentle he used him to you
know train children and yet he could
jump you know a six and a half seven
feet it was just an incredible jump
horse anyway but you know the story
reminds me about Redemption you know
here is this horse with a death sentence
and he's not only saved from death he
ends up having an abundant life and
that's really the story of the gospel
here we are on death row the penalty for
sin is death but because of Christ's
redeeming us and he didn't transfer
demons with $80 Jesus redeemed us with
his own life in his own blood you can
read about this in Galatians 3:13 Christ
redeemed us from the curse of the law by
becoming a curse for us port is written
cursed is everyone who hangs on a tree
when Jesus died on the cross it was of
course as a piece of a tree they cut
down and that he took the curse that we
deserve to give us the life that he
deserved and everyone out there can have
that life you can have that that joy
that new beginning
you can be a winner instead of a loser
when you accept Jesus you accept the
redemption that he's offered we have a
book we'd like to offer you tonight for
free to tell you about how to accept and
experience that new life and that that
life is success yes the book is called
riches of His grace and we'll be happy
to send it to anybody who calls and ask
that is our free offer for this evening
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and all you have to do is
just answer the book called riches of
His grace and will be able to send this
to anybody who calls and asks and for
those who would like to read the book
right now you can go to the amazing
facts websites it's amazing fact so our
G you can read the book for free right
there online if you have a Bible
question a phone line here to the studio
once again is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven 800 God says
for sixty three seven two ninety seven
well pastor Don I think we're ready to
take our first caller this evening and
we'll start with William and he's
listening in New York William welcome to
the program yes hello I'm pastor Doug
and um pastor Ross how are you doing I
hope everything's good with you yeah my
question thank you
my question is how long should a person
pray for another person and Jesus said
mentor always to pray and the question
is not only like for somebody sick but
like say somebody say sowing discord in
the church is something that you know
reference or that context and the thing
is that what you can't monitor really
results of what's going on in other
words they are in I don't know New
Jersey and you're in Connecticut of fun
so that's my question how long should a
person pray for a person in terms of
intercessory prayer well you know that's
a good question because first of all
keep in mind the Bible tells us that
where there's life there's hope that a
living dog is better than a dead lion
you know here you've got a lion king a
beast but if it's dead there's no hope
but a living dog at least there's hope
and that's by the way in Ecclesiastes I
don't remember the verse for that pastor
Oz may look it up but you know
theoretically if you've got a
you see I'm going to pray for this
person and through your life you keep
adding the list I knew one person that
had like 2,000 people on their prayer
list and they would pray for each of
them every day and so you know you hear
your list could get pretty long so you
just need the spirit to guide you that
doesn't mean if you stop praying for
them that their case is hopeless
I believe that prayers are actually
stored in heaven what I mean by that is
many times I've known of grandmothers or
mothers or parents that pray for their
children and the children end up being
converted but it's years after the
parents died and their earthly prayer
stopped but somehow the prayers were not
forgotten and there's many prayers you
can see in the Bible in history that are
answered long after their prey so you
know as long as the Lord the Holy Spirit
lays someone on your heart keep praying
for them if your list gets too long to
say hey Lord you stored these prayers I
don't know how the person is doing I
can't track them and I'm putting them in
your hands you know the verse you're
referring to its ecclesiastical
let's say the living dog is better than
a lion so with its life is hope yep
thank you so much and god bless both of
you I thank you William appreciate your
call and pass your off that opens up
another line actually we've got several
lines open if you've got a question give
us a call here's the number again you
ready 800 free phone call eight hundred
four six three seven two ninety seven
with your Bible question anywhere in
North America and of course around the
world via the internet we sometimes get
calls from all the way from Europe to
the Caribbean to Australia and Guam and
we invite you to call in as well one
more time North America 846 372 97 annex
holy Stephanie listening from New Mexico
Stephanie welcome to the program yes hi
my name is Stephanie how are you doing
do it well thank you for calling oh good
thanks I hope you're blessed so my
question is regarding Ephesians 4:26
through 27
the angry and do not send you not to Sun
go down on your wrath nor give place to
the devil and it kind of coincides with
first Corinthians 10:13 for me where it
talks about no temptation is common to
man but God is faithful who will not
allow you to be tempted beyond what you
are able but with the temptation will
also make way of escape that you may
have will to bear it i and i verbally
assault and I'm sinning in my anger and
so I'm trying to find out how to not do
that maybe perhaps scripture scriptural
references or how to learn how to not do
that you so you struggle with losing
your temper and thoroughly um
now there's a couple issues that could
be there first of all typically when a
person loses their temper
they have been offended and they're
retaliating somehow whether it's the
person's actions offend them you've
probably never seen a person at a
funeral that's in the casket get upset
because of something that is done to
them or said about them the reason they
don't get upset is because they're dead
and when we are crucified with Christ
and we really give up our lives to Jesus
and we realize how much Jesus suffered
for us then it's hard to be offended
it's hard to you know get upset like
that because you just have this peace
that comes into your life the passes
understanding
there's patience that doesn't mean
you're the old nature will never be
challenged but if it's a habit then you
need to just really be praying and say
Lord you know take this from me give me
your peace help me to be crucified with
Christ and and you know if you do fall
I'll go to that person and apologize
of course apologize to the Lord repent
apologize to the person every time you
do that you are programming yourself
that this is not appropriate behavior
and so be very quick
to acknowledge when you lost your temper
and and to the person into the Lord and
you're going to be reminding yourself in
the Holy Spirit you're giving the Holy
Spirit permission to change your heart
absolutely
but and and my Christian therapist
mentioned that the core that may be
unforgiveness well that is a good point
you know the the parable in Matthew
chapter 18 except this is this man that
was forgiven by the king he went out and
found someone else that owed him you
know 100 pence and took him by the
throat and the reason is he didn't
really believe they can get forgiven him
and so if you believe that Jesus is
forgiving you and how much he's forgiven
you it becomes easier now I'd like to
recommend something Stephanie that I
don't know if we recommended this in
years but we have an article on the
amazing facts website called the age of
rage and it talks about how to deal with
anger so if you go to the amazing facts
website and you type in anger you type
in the age of rage I preached the Sermon
on it and we have an article on it and
there's a lot of scripture in there I
think that will make sense to you and
give you a lot of peace okay okay thank
you so much for your help all right
Thank You Stephanie and we'll be praying
that God does give you that peace you
know we do have a book pass the devil so
cold that you wrote called tips for
resisting temptation because anger in
temptation Am's
to everyone at some form or another one
sometime and we'll be happy to send that
to you Stephanie all you're left to do
is just call and ask for a book read my
pastor dad called tips for resisting
temptation and the number is 883 five
six seven four seven that is the
resource phone number again you can
answer the book called tips for
resisting contagion anybody can call and
ask if you have a question our phone
line here to the studio is 800 463 a
seventy to ninety seven eight hundred
four sixty three seventy to ninety seven
our next caller is joseph listening in
Queens New York
Joseph welcome to the program Joseph
you're on the air hi pastors rich
authority again thanks reward
thank you thanks for calling okay my
questions in our Genesis 43 okay it
starts up yes
Genesis 43 it starts off with now the
famine in the was severe in the land but
then in chapter 11
Israel's telling his sons that take the
best fruits nuts and almonds - as a gift
to Egypt to Joseph so if there's a
famine in the land whether he fruits and
nuts council well that's a very good
question I've read that before and even
in a famine some trees will do okay what
typically happens in these famines is
the the rains they don't supply the
crops they give the grain the principal
food of any country is going to be some
form of bread whether it's rice corn
wheat and in the Land of Israel they
grew barley and they grew wheat and if
the weather messed up the crops it
didn't mean that none of the almond
trees were reproducing or there'd be no
fruit or no honey I think that they sent
down some of the honey so basically was
saying when he said the best he didn't
mean that they had a lot he meant what
is the best that we can give as a gift
to this man and it may have been very
expensive for them sometimes these
special fruits were actually brought by
traders it came from countries where
there was no famine and so the caravans
would bring things and they would buy
them with their sheep and goats so what
they brought to Joseph as a gift may not
have come locally so he pointed to the
best in the land he meant the best that
we've got I see I was under the
impression of famine was nothing at all
rose in the land
no there's yeah some things would
survive but the main thing is that if
there's no grain if there's no grass the
Sheep the cattle start to die there's no
bread it doesn't mean there's nothing I
really there's some vegetables and
things that you can water by hand and
keep a few things alive now in this
century
can I ask another quick question turn
very quick okay I just have work
I have worked in the hospital and a
woman was praying aloud and she was
every sentence would start off in her
crash you start off but I prophesy
hypothesize my son's gonna pass that
test i prophesied that someone's going
to be healed it just caught my attention
I never heard anybody pray that was
about to use the word hypothesize and
we're interested okay well you know of
course even prophets did not say i
prophesy my guess would be based on my
worshiping with christians from many
different denominations this person is
part of a prosperity evangelical
congregation and they often you know
they preach that you just you declare
what you want and by saying i'm
promising this is going to happen by
your declaring it it will happen that's
usually associated with you know some of
the ministries like kenneth copeland and
some others that's my guess but I don't
know for sure but I've just heard I have
heard that before yeah it's just in some
properties kind of figure well yeah we
need to humbly ask the Lord we don't
tell the Lord what to do yes I mean it
sounded can you a little blessing are
you kind of declaring yourself a prophet
I guess if I say I prophesied yeah well
you know some people go to churches
where the pastor will say you've got to
give to prophesy and a person thinks
everything they say is going to come
true and it could be a form of
self-deception all right hey appreciate
your question Joseph you have a good
evening
okay thank you guys thank you god bless
you no Joseph there might be a book that
I think you'd find interesting schools
teach us to pray and we'll send this to
you if you just call and ask absolutely
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven not only for you but for anyone
wanting to learn more about how do we
pray and we'll be happy to send you the
book eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven the book again is
called teach us to pray and if you have
a Bible question good time to pick up
the phone and give us a call we have
some lines that are open the number here
to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven eight hundred four
sixty three seventy to ninety seven if
you call now there's a good chance we
will be able to get your
on the air before we take a break
halfway through the hour our next call
is Richard listening from Illinois
Richard welcome to the program thank you
thank you for taking my call and God's
blessings to you sir thank you and I am
a chaplain with the Sheriff's Department
and I kind of struggled with John 3
where is talking about Jesus is talking
to Nicodemus about being born of the
water and of the Spirit right ah I have
been among logos as we speak bogus and
I see all different kinds of
commentaries up here from Romans to new
pillared Testament Bible knowledge
commentary teachers commentary and I got
all different kinds of answers so I want
to pose that question to you and and see
what your thought of well Jesus was
exactly referring to when he said water
Candice spirit all right
yeah well we're happy to essaouira hat
in the ring witzy yeah the other comment
earlier but I have said in this verse
I'll just say for our listeners benefit
let me read the verse unless a person is
born of the water in the spirit and this
is by the way John 3:3 most assuredly
are truly truly I say to you unless one
is born of the water and the spirit
actually is verse 5 he cannot enter the
kingdom of God
some believe when it says born of the
water there it's talking about when a
baby is born naturally meaning right in
an envelope of water born of the water
born of the spirit of course the
spiritual Bernie others believe born of
the water means baptism I agree that's
what I was that yeah I'm of that second
group I believe that when you read John
in John chapter 1 and 2 there's great
emphasis on the Ministry of John the
Baptist Jesus is introduced to the
disciples in the
of John the Baptist baptizing Matthew
and Luke talk about the birth of Christ
John begins his gospel by going right
into the subject of baptism right out of
the gate so there's that heavy emphasis
the other thing is if Jesus was to say
unless you're born of a woman and born
of the Spirit you cannot enter the
kingdom of heaven that's sort of a
redundant thing to say because we were
listening to my voice was not born of a
woman everyone is born of Roman now when
the children of Israel came out of Egypt
Paul says they went through the Red Sea
and they were baptized in the sea and
that was John a rather first Corinthians
chapter 10 and then they were baptized
in the pillar of fire the cloud so they
were born of the water baptism and they
were born of the Spirit you've got both
baptisms happening baptism of water is
your choice baptism of spirit is God's
choice we choose Lord I want to follow
you it's a public declaration I want to
be washed away from my sins and then God
baptizes us with the spirit in his
timing
right right well that's that's exactly
what I thought was more of the baptism
and so I'm glad that is a question just
I want to make sure I'm correct on that
as well you know I think there's another
added component of baptism in the Old
Covenant in the Old Testament
circumcision became the sign of the Old
Covenant and baptism becomes the sign of
the New Covenant
so when someone surrenders to Christ
Jesus said we need to be baptized that
is a public declaration that we're
correct entering into the New Covenant
relationship with Christ yeah these are
the last words of Jesus go there for
teach all nations baptizing them so it
was obviously a priority of Christ and
that it was his last words as he
ascended to heaven and then also I
wanted to comment on that book of rage I
want to I think it was age of rage or
whatever oh the article yeah
yeah I'd like to get more information on
that because I deal with a lot of people
with those issues yeah you can the
magazine is actually a magazine article
you can download for free at the amazing
facts website which is simply amazing
facts oh oh our G and the article is
called the age of rage but if you even
type that in you'll probably get a
sermon that I preached so you can either
listen to the sermon read the article
there's things in the sermon that aren't
in the article but you'll get them both
hey thank you very much for your call
Richard we're going to try to get one
more call before the break and we do
still have lines open so give us a call
Mick Foley is a wrestler listening from
North Carolina right now after the
program all right how are you doing yeah
thank you
I've been reading one of your books and
is talking about the four empires that
rose Babylon media Greece and Rome and
you can see where the Lord kind of spoke
to Babylon media but later on when
Greece and Rome come into power he
doesn't really talk to him and I also
wondered all what happened what change
between those two nations because he
talked with Nebuchadnezzar and Cyrus so
with about Medes and Persians but you
don't really see any interaction with
the Greeks and the Romans am I right or
wrong here well I I think that I see
what you're saying I do think that the
Lord tried to reach both those other
kingdoms because you have in Josephus
history he says when Alexander the Great
came to Jerusalem the priest came out to
him and read to him the prophecies of
Daniel that talked about Greece ruling
the world Alexander did not attack
Jerusalem he showed great favor to them
he came in to their temple and
worshipped God and then pretty much left
them in peace so there was some
influence between the Jews on Alexander
the Great and of course the Romans they
were ruling the world when Jesus was
born Jesus himself spoke to Pontius
Pilate and some of the other Roman
leaders some of them did believe Paul
preached to Nero as did Peter I think
Peter at least had an audience with him
before he was executed so
there were representatives from all
those empires that did interact with the
leaders and of course the reason they
specifically mentioned is because of the
role that they had with reference to
God's people Israel and it was of course
during that time period you have Babylon
the Jews are captives in Babylon it was
a metre Persian Empire the Persian in
particular that allowed them to go back
and restore and rebuild Jerusalem then
you have the story of the Greeks and
their influence that they had on the
people of Israel and then of course Rome
and you have the whole experience with
Jesus and the Apostles and preaching the
gospel
so those four empires are connected with
God's people and with the promise of the
coming Redeemer yet ultimately if you
track the history down Christians did
have some influence on Roman leadership
in that Constantine at least professed
to be a Christian and legalized it in
the in the kingdom so that they was able
to spread or as it brought and other
problems but hey friends we're going to
take break we do still have lines open
that number again 800 God says 804 637
297 got more Bible questions on the way
and sometimes we save the best for last
so stay tuned listen to these important
announcements stay tuned
Bible answers live will return in a
moment
[Music]
nice a curious thing I mean just when
things seemed under control wham you hit
with something new
your marriage is good suddenly it's on
the brink of divorce that jobs great and
then it's gone and social life savings
you feel healthy and a doctor gives the
bad news coming next you could look to
the stars the stable know the answer a
distance prophecy Study Bible my amazing
facts
this Bible special its 27 personal study
guides lead you on a life-changing
journey to God's Word to discover real
answers to life's questions from health
and relationships family and future
hopes in here get your amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible today by calling
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 seventy to
ninety seven will bring your Bible
question into our studios here in the
capital of California so give us a call
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross and we ready to go back to the
phone lines we've got Steve listening in
Michigan
Steve welcome to the program ah
Shalom Aleichem brothers how are you
doing assuming doing well thanks and you
blessed and highly favored thank you
very much
my question tonight is the infamous
difference of opinion between Matthew
28:19 which you're somewhat alluded to
with one of the previous callers
questions about John three and acts 2:38
and then in addition to that of the fact
that I'm curious as to why churches
today are leaving it up to parishioners
or whatever you want to call them to
make a choice to be baptized or not when
indeed the Bible clearly indicates that
is a command how to request all right
well first of all I agree with you that
baptism in the Bible is not a suggestion
it's clearly commanded when jesus told
His disciples both in Matthew 16 and
acts 2 several times in acts actually
Matthew 28 and throughout the Gospels
that when people were to repent and be
baptized and so yeah it is it is a
priority it's baptism is as important to
a Christian as a wedding is to a
marriage baptism is the ceremony by
which we publicly say we are accepting
Christ so it's very important now when
you talk about Matthew 28 and acts 2 I
think you might be asking about why does
Jesus say in Matthew 28 go be baptized
in the name of the Father Son and Holy
Spirit and in acts 2:38 it says be
baptized in the name of the Lord is that
what you're wondering are the baptized
in the name of Jesus Christ well yeah
actually both because here's where I
find a lot of confusion when I'm talking
to people out on the streets and whatnot
is the fact that if you break it down
Matthew 20 19 is very poignant on the
name it's not the names or the titles it
is the name of so you see obedience to
Matthew 28:19 when indeed you obey acts
2 in 38 also then you get into the the
other portion ever where his disciples
are they rebaptised other ones so you
know the confusion comes in I guess is a
versatile to the Trinitarian version or
the oneness version which is actually
the correct I'm not saying that's
actually correct but I'm saying which is
the correct mode because it would seem
that as I say obeying acts 2:38 is a
fulfillment of Matthew 28:19 in other
words you're saying that of course Jesus
gives the marching orders in Matthew 28
but you see how they fulfilled it when
you get to Acts correct yeah well let me
explain the oneness to our listeners
just because some I know what you're
talking about some might wonder in the
oneness teaching in this you know a
group of Christian
known as oneness pentecostals they
believe that there is one God who
manifests himself in three different
modes sometimes he is seen as the son
sometimes as the father sometimes as a
spirit but he's really they're all one
in the same I respectfully disagree with
that teaching and one reason that I
think is a strong argument is that the
baptism of Jesus you have Jesus in the
water you've got the father speaking
from heaven and unless you know Jesus is
a ventriloquist you've got at least a
couple beans in different places and
then you have got the spirit coming down
in a third form simultaneously as a dove
and so you can see the three different
persons of the Godhead in different
locations in that verse and then of
course it does say in Genesis God said
let us make man in our image Elohim is
using a plural term so while I agree
about the importance of baptism I think
it's important that we are baptized in
the name of the Father Son of the Spirit
if a person is baptized in the name of
the Lord in the name of the Lord Jesus
Christ that I think is just as valid
because in Acts there are three
different phrases that are used one time
it says in the name of the Lord one time
and then it says in the name of Jesus
Christ and I think one time it says in
the name of the Lord Jesus and so it's
clear to me if it's mentioned four
different ways in the Gospels are in the
New Testament the exact wording of the
baptism declaration was not a priority
in that it's it's almost never mentioned
the same way so it's like with a wedding
there are certain components in a
wedding that need to be followed when
the pastor Austin I've done several
weddings and when you do a wedding it
can be very formal you can see the bride
and the groom's full names or you can
say do you build take Sally and they can
be more informal but as long as you are
making those vows to individuals in the
presence of witnesses those are the
things that make a covenant binding
baptism as long as you get the elements
of the Covenant that you're declaring
your allegiance to the God of the Bible
accepting Jesus as your Savior in the
presence of these witnesses you know if
the if the pastor lisps when he says the
baptism it's not invalid right does that
mean I'm going along yeah going on at
same sense of what in your estimation
then is the correct or biblical correct
way of baptism well any one of the four
ways oh the correct method is baptism by
immersion there's the only example in
the Bible that you see is it says the
Jesus went down into the water John the
Baptist baptized in a river it wasn't
with a canteen he could have done it in
Jerusalem or above it so and then when
the Philip the Philip baptizes the
Ethiopian treasure they go down into the
water they come up out of the water
there were very word baptized is from
the Greek word baptizo it means to
immerse they tell you what Steve we're
going to run to another call but I want
to send you a free book and it's on
baptism it's called baptism isn't
necessary and it answers all these
questions the number to call is eight
hundred eight thirty five six seven four
seven and the book is called baptism
isn't necessary we'd have to send it to
you Steve or anybody who calls and asks
next Holies mark listening in sacramento
california mark welcome to the program
oh thank you very much pastors god bless
you both and thanks for taking my calls
yes so I have a question um there is a
book in the New Testament there is
chapter and verse which I don't know the
name of written by Paul which says and I
paraphrase that women should not speak
up or act up in church and I just have
no idea what that really means I was
hoping you could clarify that for me all
right
pastor Ross is looking up as a few
different verses you could be referring
to and I think he's going to be looking
those up for us um you know if you look
in first Timothy 2:12 he says but I
suffer not a woman to teach or to usurp
authority over the man but to be in
silence is that the one you're talking
about there's another one in first
14:34 says let your woman keep silent in
the churches for they are not permitted
to speak but they are to be submissive
as the law also says so I believe that's
the louvers and I've been wondering
about yeah I don't think enough some
have wondered and there are very few
Christians there are some but there are
very few Christian churches that take
this verse to mean that a woman is not
to open your mouth and say anything in
the church because I know there are I've
been in some churches where they do take
a pretty strong stand that the women
should not speak in the church but
that's rare I most understand that this
is addressing a particular problem that
they were having a principally in the
Corinthian church men and women didn't
sit together if I've been in many
churches pastor Ross has to in India or
other parts of the Middle East for the
men and women don't even sit together in
Orthodox Jewish congregations it's that
way
and the women evidently were calling
over to their husbands and asking
questions or explaining things their
husbands didn't seem to understand and
it was embarrassing the husbands that
their women were teaching them in front
of everybody and Paul said don't do that
you know you're supposed to respect your
husband let him be the priest of the
family and and discuss these things at
home but you have examples in the women
in the Bible of women filled with the
spirit speaking in church
you've got Anna when Jesus was born who
prophesize in the temple you've got
Hannah who goes to the temple and she
prays and she declares his prophecy and
there are a number of women prophets in
the Bible so I I don't think I would
ever take these verses to mean that a
woman cannot teach or speak in a church
perfect that answers the question for me
pastors thank you so much for taking my
call I really appreciate it maybe
absolutely by the way mark we do have a
book we'll send you a free copy if you'd
like it I wrote a couple years ago and
it's called women in ministry and it
answers a number of the
these verses and other questions the
number the call for that is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called woman in ministry again
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven we have Terry is
listening from Michigan Terry welcome to
the program
thank you so much god bless both of you
pastors i tune in every week to get
knowledge and learning of the bible also
tune in to amazing facts because I
really really love your teaching is just
playing it's simple it's difficult and
easy to understand so god bless both of
y'all this evening well bless your thank
you my question yeah this is my question
what does anointed mean I hear this term
used so much he's anointed to speak he's
anointed to teach season knowing that
you think and part two to that is is it
possible to lose your anointed I decided
in ministering myself and actually got
ran across my mind all day yesterday and
it's on my mind all day today because
you go through trials you go through
tribulations sometimes you pray you
don't think that the power of God is
with you anymore for whatever still
might remain in your life whatever type
of sin might be holding you back so my
question is what does it mean to be
anointed and is it possible to lose that
anointing god bless both be on this
evening and continue to do the work of
Christ God bless all right well they
were steering don't hang up on I won't
hang up on element let me do my best to
try and answer your question first of
all what does anointing mean the word
anointing it means well if if you were
going to go to the beach and you're
really afraid of being burned you might
have someone slather you with suntan
lotion they would anoint you anointing
means to some people before they cook
their turkey they baste it with butter
or something and that means they try to
saturate it and spread something all
over it means to slather to cover with
oil when the high priest was chosen
they put oil on his head when a king was
chosen they used to pour oil on him and
they called it anointing the
the word when you christen a ship this
is where you get the word Christos
Christos is the Greek word for anoint
Messiah is the Hebrew word for anoint
Jesus was anointed the Bible says with
the Holy Spirit that means he was filled
he was covered with the Holy Spirit so
when someone is saying they've been
anointed to this ministry or with the
spirit it means that basically the Holy
Spirit has been poured on them mm-hmm
but those are what the words mean
technically and can a person lose the
anointing yes you have examples in the
Bible of people that grieved away the
Spirit of God and in even Paul warns us
in Ephesians I think it's visions to
Pastor Ross grieve not the Holy Spirit
that anoints us so you know we can hurt
the spirit and kind of drive them out of
our lives by you know you've heard the
unpardonable sin if we have plug our
ears to the ongoing pleas of the Spirit
then we could you know drive that spirit
away so you know actually if would you
know for yourself if you actually doing
something to greet the Holy Spirit
because you'll feel convicted yeah the
next one of anything going on yeah one
of the things the Holy Spirit does for
you is he brings conviction the danger
is when you get to the point where you
continue to ignore the Holy Spirit and
you don't feel the conviction anymore
because you've turned down the volume so
low by resisting that you're kind of
rearing up the spirit right hey you know
we've got a book that talks about the
Holy Spirit we'll be happy to send you a
free copy and it's called life in the
spirit and I think diversity referring
to pastor Doug Ephesians chapter 4 verse
13 says do not grieve the Holy Spirit by
whom you are sealed or anointed for the
day of redemption
yes Ephesians 4:30 if you'd like to
receive that book that we just offered
you the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven that's 883 five six
seven four seven and we'll be happy to
send that to anybody who calls and asks
an actual is John listening in Canada
John welcome to the
program hi John you on the air Alberta
Canada hi thanks for having me I'm sorry
I'm driving through the mountain so you
may have a hard time right they get cut
off well do your best to escape the
question real quick there you are I well
so I just forgot a minute been
struggling with my face lately i watch a
lot of debates on you know ages versus
you know some of the better you know
religious minds out there and I'm sure
you probably familiar with all the ones
that I you know the more popular one
anyway so my struggle is why should I
trust the Bible it can't really read the
Bible and say oh the Bible says it's
true so it must be true but I was
brought up in the church so I you know
I've always had that religious
foundation but what I'm struggling with
lately well I'm with you John I don't
want to believe the Bible because the
Bible says believe the Bible that sort
of is a pretty weak argument I came at
the Bible believing it was a fairy tale
and before I started believing it I was
amazed by the evidence when the Bible
for told things years in advance and
then they happened and you know from
history that the Bible the parts of the
Bible that it prophesied were written
years before the events were fulfilled
very precisely the evidence that there
is a supernatural influence in the Bible
I think became overpowering many
examples you look for instance in the
book of Daniel that we know was written
many years before Christ from the Dead
Sea Scrolls
Daniel lays out four major kingdoms of
the world that and even names them as
Babylon Persia Greece and the fourth one
Rome isn't named right away but he does
name the first three and then they all
happen in that same succession and
Greece was just in a warring tribes when
daniel says they're going to rule the
world and they'll have one great king
and it's Alexander the Great
interrupts they know when Daniel was
ready yeah we're pretty sure Daniel and
I could go well I think it there's a lot
of substantiation in his well yeah we we
know for
fact that Daniel was written prior to
Christ because of the Dead Sea Scrolls
we know that's been David and then this
prophecy is given in the Book of Daniel
that met their fulfillment exactly after
Christ the Babylonian captivity was some
600 years BC Daniel was the captive in
Babylon we have archaeological evidence
to testify of the truth of
Nebuchadnezzar and Cyrus and the
Babylonian captivity the rebuilding of
the temple so with the archaeological
evidence as well as the historical finds
the Dead Sea Scrolls and alike it's
pretty clear that yes the prophecies of
Daniel were written before they occurred
and especially the ones relating to
after Christ and the dividing up of the
Roman Empire the ten Germanic tribes
that invaded and carved up Western
Europe it's just remarkable out
accurately they've been fulfilled okay
yeah that sounds great can I ask I don't
know you're just the first time I've
heard your show so I don't know your
beliefs but are you are you um I guess
literalists that you know the creation
story yep we believe I think I can speak
to pastor Ross that we do believe that
the Lord made the world in six literal
days now do you struggle with that very
much so you know I used to be I wanted
to be a paleontologist I believed in
evolution all my life until I started
reading the Bible and boy I wish I had
more time with you but we we probably
can't go deep into it but sure there's
scientist I believe the world is made in
six literal days are scientific reasons
they're not just because the Bible says
so but hey you know we've got a free
book that we can send you and it's
called is there anything left you can
trust and we'll send you that study
guide and it gives practical reasons why
the Bible is a supernatural book that
you can believe again the number to call
is eight hundred eight thirty five six
seven four seven you can ask the study
guide called is there anything left you
can trust and also John a couple other
resources you might find helpful if you
go to the amazing facts website just
amazing facts so are G and we have some
some articles you can read we have some
videos that you can watch
dealing with the trustworthiness of
Scripture also some some videos some
sermons that recount history I'm
thinking of the new Emily we did the
bride the Beast and Gavilan and we
coming up with a brand new documentary
DVD hopefully by the end of the year
that looks at 40 of the most compelling
prophecies in the Bible that have been
proven true from history and archaeology
and I think anybody who's wondering
about the trustworthiness of Scripture
will be encouraged if they take a look
at that video and hopefully as I said
check back with the website we're hoping
to have that done by the end of the year
yep hey thank you for your call John and
we'd love to hear from you again next
coli's Ronnie and he is listening in
Illinois Ronnie welcome to the program
hi hi Doug and pastor John Ross are you
going tonight good good thanks for your
call okay thank you for taking my call
I've been listening to you guys for like
seven years now I had a question for you
ah now Moses Elijah and Enoch have had
went to be with Jesus in heaven and my
question is is do you believe that they
are working with Jesus to build heaven
for us well there is a story in mark
chapter 9 where Moses and the Elijah
come and speak with Jesus when he was
here on earth I'm sure when Christ is in
heaven he's in regular communication
with these three humans who have been
resurrected and taken to heaven whether
they're actively involved in helping him
build the mansions or something like
that I don't know that would just be
speculation I'm sure they're the only
interested in the plan of redemption and
what's happening here on earth and the
work of Christ because yes the work of
Moses Elijah and Enoch was all about
preparing people for eternity and so you
know they were all interested in God's
work and his people saving his people so
today they are interested in seeing the
church succeed yes okay I see come Jesus
said that one of his last words was to
us is that he would leave and go into
paradise for us
and and they all left before him so I
was just wondering if maybe they were
working with him or not
and you're on California right now right
correct
yeah I was born and raised out there you
know it's like your spiritual warfare
front line out there yeah they need the
gospel here just like everywhere but the
California is its own country it is it
is well thank you for taking hey thank
you guys I appreciate your appreciate
your call all right Mick Scola is jeanna
listening from Rio Linda California
Jeana welcome to the program
thank you so much back to Doug and
Pastor John please my question is about
please would you explain in times last
legs
what what's dealing with the last the
plagues the seven last plagues in
Revelation please yep that's Roger we'll
take a stab at that and yeah you find
revelation talks about seven last
plagues that occurred just before Jesus
comes and first of all we know that the
plagues the seven last plagues really
affect the wicked not the righteous it's
referred to as the wrath of God that is
poured out upon the wicked just before
Jesus camps during the time of the place
God's people the righteous they will be
protected you have Psalm 91 that speaks
about no plague coming near your
dwelling so that's going to take care of
these people but the plays do serve an
important purpose they ripen the harvest
to the same coming of Jesus referred to
as a harvest you got the harvest of the
wheat representing the righteous to get
the harvest of the grapes representing
the wickedness Revelation chapter 14 so
just before Jesus comes the plagues will
actually reveal the hard-heartedness and
rebellion of the wicked without actually
cursed God because the plagues so it's a
clear evidence that they have committed
the unpardonable sin they have hardened
their hearts against God and that's
importantly the great controversy theme
that occurs in a real quick nutshell
that's a little bit about the seven last
plagues thank you very much
absolutely I'm just trying to think if
we we don't really have a lesson that
talks about the seven last plagues not
specifically now on offer yeah not too
many people want a lesson on the place
but we do have a great material at our
website that talks about mattify we have
some sermons to deal with it yeah on the
other end thank you very much for your
call Gina next Holi is a Rick listening
from Maryland Rick welcome in the
program
i pastor doug ross i recently the other
guy was talking about the creation being
a six literal days I recently just
returned from a trip to the Creation
Museum in Northern Kentucky and Noah's
Ark which is where two separate museums
but they're connected there started by
Ken Ham yeah are you familiar with those
museums yeah I know Ken him yeah okay
Bob I've never been to the museum's but
I know a lot of people have been there
really enjoy it was fantastic my wife
and I loved it but the question I have
of course the emphasis at hand but
there's some very good arguments about
the earth being thousands of years old
as opposed to millions of billions and
of course they had a famous debate
between Ken Ham and Bill Nye the Science
Guy and I'm in the process of this is
listening to those CDs but I would
always was of thought that the earth was
millions of years old not billions but
coming away from there I tell you it
really was the 15 arguments that Kim had
presented that were to me were you know
mind-blowing to me and I you know I know
it slides in a space of science but yet
you know but you know it really does my
plane it doesn't fly in the face of
science I think that the scientific
evidence is for a short history on earth
and I think there's a lot of good
support for that you know it must forget
past that I guess some of the most well
educated and while studied professionals
and professors and scientists many of
which are recognized creation as being
the evidence leaning more towards of
creation by design God being involved
the earth be made in six little
so yeah we don't wanna get the idea that
somehow the Bible is opposed or fighting
the science we need to look at the
science and compared it with Scripture
absolutely
hey thank you very much for your call
and Rob you know we do have a book
called the wonders of creation that
you'll find encouraging also one called
when science I'm sorry when evolution
flunked the science test or evolution
flink the science test and listening
friends we are running short on time for
the Bible question part we do still have
some important announcements to share
with you but keep in mind Jesus is the
truth that sets you free we'd love to
hear from you go to amazing facts dot
o-r-g and let us know you enjoy the
program god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love and great sacrifice but
behind him is another hero hidden in
plain sight amid the shadows he was
there from the beginning and he'll be
there until the end discover the golden
thread of a savior woven throughout the
entire Bible tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible a new book by Doug Batchelor get
your copy today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
spiring books DVDs and more to help you
get the most out of God's Word to take
advantage of the offers you've heard on
this broadcast call us at
[Music]